[Applause]
very good
um very happy to be here first and
foremost i'm very happy to
see all those lovely faces all those
it's a very diverse hall
um amsterdam has a lot of muslims in it
and from different places of the world
so i'm very happy to be
in your beautiful country in your
beautiful city very clean by the way
you know um yes it's a very clean city
we're just kind of observing things and
good infrastructure
lots of things to talk about but to
delve right into the topic
um now i used to work as a teacher right
and
this is how we used to start every
lesson with high school kids we used to
have objectives
so i haven't kind of lost that touch
still got that a little bit these are
the objectives of today right i've got a
laser here
so the first objective is to know the
first principles basic history of
liberalism
number two is to compare islamic
traditionalism and obviously these are
all key words
right um and liberal contractarianism in
particular i'll tell you what that means
as well and number three is to be able
to make a judgment based on those
comparisons
now obviously here when we're doing a
comparative study
we're talking about two things
fundamentally we're talking about
similarities and differences
so when we talk about liberalism and
islam or islamic traditionalism
which will come to define um what we're
going to be doing
is we're going to be looking at not just
points of conflict and tension
but we are going to also be looking at
points of overlap
and i think that's the healthy approach
some people like the brother mentioned
masha'allah very
very well i really applaud his approach
on this one
um some people have this conversation in
a different kind of way in an
apologetic kind of way you know and that
is because as he's mentioned we're
minority groups in this country
so we're asked lots of questions all the
time we're asked about
things that relate to human rights right
and human rights have become
a buzzword right very important you know
after 1948 as we'll come to know
the convention the euro the the human
convention uh human rights convention
with the 30 articles have become almost
like scripture
so questions like you know your religion
is against human rights for x y z reason
and this kind of trajectory that we're
introduced to which
assumes that we have to go from the
primitive kind of state that we're in
right now
and follow through the european um kind
of
progress trajectory that the christians
have already done
and we need to now follow the same kind
of you know the same kind of course
and of course there are a lot of
presuppositions and assumptions with
this which we are going to
discover but the first thing we need to
kind of talk about is
what is referred to as the
epistemological basis
okay of of of liberalism now it's a big
word what does this mean
epistemology is how you get to know
making sense of the world making sense
of making sense of the world
basically how do you know about the
world right
when we're talking about the
epistemological basis of liberalism in
particular we're talking about
what grounds liberalism what are the
assumptions of liberalism
what are the first principles of
liberalism now what are first principles
generally
you can break something down like for
example this thing here
or a mobile phone you can break it down
to smaller constituent parts
okay everything is broken down to basic
parts
those are the first principles of the
thing
so when we're talking about the first
principles we're asking if we break
liberalism down to the lowest common
multiple if you like
to its kind of basic building blocks
what are we left with
what what is the foundation by which
liberalism is built on you can't build
you know castles
on thin air can you right i mean i'm
sure
you guys know in amsterdam you've got
great infrastructure you've got
incredible engineers here right so it's
about foundation what are the
foundations
you know of liberalism and so to know
that you have to look at the basic
philosophy of liberalism
and if you look at that you'll find that
there are some themes which
are consistent and what are the themes
that are consistent basically
if you look at the works of all the way
from john locke who is
you could argue the founding father of
liberalism a man called john locke
you could say he's the founding father
of liberalism all the way down to john
rules
who was probably the martin last major
contributor of liberalism
you'll find that they believed in
something called the hedonistic
principle
now the hedonistic principle is simple
right it's about
pain and pleasure it's as simple as that
they argued that morality should be
premised predicated
aligned with pain
the human propensity to pain and
pleasure
and the idea was you should maximize as
much pleasure
as you can and you should minimize as
much pain
as possible this is the you know the
most desirable and moral way to live
this evolved as we'll find out into
something called utilitarianism
which is the literally the greatest good
for the greatest number
the greatest good for the greatest
number so eventually this made
this meant that we are trying to
maximize pleasure
for as many people as possible
and we are trying to also by extension
minimize pain for as many people as
possible that's the
the model that's point one number two is
you'll be quite surprised
is theology now if you look at the work
of for example john locke you'll find
that he often time makes reference to
god
he says we are created equal right
and remember when he was writing his
major book called the two treatises of
government
he was writing writing it to someone
called robert filmer and he was arguing
using the bible
so a lot of the things here and this is
an important point and i want everyone
to remember this right
a lot of the assumptions of liberalism
depend upon a theological backing
in other words the fact that we were
created equal
listen to the terminology here you're
that's taken from john locke it was put
into the declaration of independence it
was put into
the constitutions of major countries
like america and france
but it's taken from john locke he was a
theist he believed in god
now the question is now obviously in
europe especially western europe there's
a rise in atheism
but you still find that atheist
politicians
use the same kind of terminology we're
equal we're born equal
now the question is well john locke had
god to promise that one
he had god to predicate that on he had
the bible to go back on
but what do you have now as an atheist
how can you prove as an atheist
right or naturalism say or something
else
that you are born equal in fact on
naturalism
we're not born equal in fact on
naturalism we're fundamentally
unequal why because you've got someone
like me
who's about six foot six
yes and someone
else might be much shorter you have
black people and white people you have
people who are born in different
geographic places and have different
kind of opportunities as a result
people who are born disabled who people
who are born
conjoined to a twin people who are born
in this way and that naturalistically
where is the equality here
in fact one thing we can guarantee is
inequality even with twins you have
different fingerprints
everything on naturalism is unequal for
an atheist then to say look
we're born equal on what basis because
actually john locke was
arguing using god before so what are you
arguing base
basing what are you basing this on
so you know a straightforward question
to an atheist liberal
how can you prove that we're born equal
how are you going to do that in fact
evolution
the theory of darwinian evolution
would tell us and not just darwinian
evolution any other kind of
outgrowth of evolution would tell us
that actually we're not born equal in
fact it's survival of the fittest
that we are we have no tendency to
equality at all in fact we have a
tendency
to survival and reproduction so on what
basis are we born equal
you see this discussion
which has now permeated the mass media
and infiltrated almost every academic
circle in the west
is predicated on something
which has been dumped away in the
dustbin of history which is religion
for the most part i mean obviously
there's lots of christian liberals who
can justify this
or jewish liberals who can say well
actually we still believe in equality
but then we go to the bible and see what
kind of equality does the bible talk
about
seriously that's what we're gonna have
to do now how does the bible define
equality
that's the discussion now and that was
the discussion by the way that robert
filmer
and john locke were having in the
beginning they were both making
references to the story of genesis
and the bible and all these things
so what equality do you mean exactly and
that's important
now
we we talked about john rules this was a
guy who was
you know he's a very influential
individual
and he came he's one of the he's
probably one of the individuals who
people do their phds on now he's one of
the only individuals people still do
their phds on
in in the liberal thought he's probably
the last one they do that on he's like
in terms of contribution his
contribution was quite
big and he's probably the biggest you
know philosopher in the 20th century
in in europe and
he he argued for equality on a different
kind of basis we'll talk about how he
argued for equality
but this is my claim and i'll come back
to it and i want you to remember it
all liberal thinkers who argue on the
basis of equality
as a first principle either do so number
one religiously
as we've seen with john locke or number
two with reference and i'm going to use
my terms
blatantly here with reference to a type
of mythology
and you're going to say what are you
talking about how can you substantiate
that yes
there is such a thing as liberal myth
and we're going to just
uncover and unearth today what we mean
by liberal myth
because usually when sorry to say the
white man or let's say the westerner
when they use the word myth in circles
or if you look at vernacularly in the
dictionary
what do you let's be honest what do you
have in your mind when i say myth
you have some hindu god in your mind you
have greek gods in your mind that's what
you have
in your mind let's be honest right you
might even have genesis in your mind
you might even have quranic images in
your mind
why because that is the orientalist
understanding of what a myth is
it's a story of some sorts which is not
substantiated in real history isn't it
so to what extent is liberalism based on
a story which
is predicated on a real history that's
an important discussion
we'll come to it so
individualism is another kind of thing
which liberalism
i mean not all of liberalism but a large
part of it kind of promotes and this
individualism is
this the idea that
human beings know what's best for them
okay so individualism
it literally comes from individual right
that the individual knows what's best
for him if you abstract the individual
you take them out of their social
circles and their community and their
country and so on
that individual by themselves is better
off
knowing what's best for them and
obviously
even now to be honest to be fair there's
a new debate that's circling which is
individualism versus communitarianism
now communitarianism
you have people like michael sandell
who's right now one of the biggest
scholars in
probably the western world talking about
liberalism
and he talks about communitarianism he
says no
he says human beings are not individual
in that way we're all interdependent
communities are actually more effective
than individuals in terms of social
organization so there's a big
discussion now between individualism and
communitarianism
it's a new debate all right so in terms
of history to get
straight into the thick of it the
question is when did
liberalism kind of begin so
you could say liberalism began out of
england and i'm not saying that because
i'm
a british guy and i'm trying to enforce
my you know history on you
it came out you could say it was around
this time around the 1600s which is
about the 17th century so the mid 17th
century
when you had english civil war
now the english civil war was a long and
drawn out
kind of war you can look it up i'm not
going into that too much
otherwise i will feel like i'm back in
um school
it's and then then you have something
with a bit of rights now the thing is
now here with the bill of rights
the question is the question the
all-important question was
to what extent should government's power
be limited
and obviously at this time you had
tensions between the monarchy and
parliament
and we wanted to know what parliament
how much power should be given to
the sovereign which in this case is
parliament
so john locke who died in 1706 actually
contributed to this discourse massively
because when he wrote his book the two
treaties of government
this was incorporated in to the bill of
rights which is a
very important document in english law
this is which was written in 1689
so a lot of his ideas his what would
then become liberal ideas
about you know life property
uh you know uh these these important
things that you have to be protected the
protectables right
so for example life and property etc
that would be incorporated into the bill
of rights so this was a turning point
you could say in the history of
liberalism now john locke died around
which is the early 18th century so in
terms of
liberalism and its developments you
could argue that it became known really
as a tradition
in around the 18th century
which means it's quite a young tradition
in the grand scheme of things it's about
300 years old
so after that you had the obviously the
us founding fathers
and the documents that were associated
with the found you know the beginning of
the the you know the republic of united
states
and a lot of john locke's ideas and and
other people's ideas were incorporated
into those documents
so once again liberalism started to
become institutionalized
and it became the it became the slowly
it's becoming the dominant ethic now
don't forget religion was very important
at this time as well
but if you look at the the rising
importance of liberalism
you'll find that it coincided with the
decline of
enthusiasm about religion so people were
becoming more
enthusiastic about liberalism about an
ideology which
in in and of itself you don't you
couldn't argue is
abrahamic for example in religious uh
complexion
it was something different and they're
becoming less enthusiastic about
they're becoming less enthusiastic about
christianity
you had someone like rousseau who was a
very important figure
and sorry he died in 1778
obviously this is not an exhaustive list
of you know
this is just a suggestive list to show
you some key points of history
and we said that the not only did the
usa
have an important impact but france as
well because as you guys know
france was founded on these kinds of
ideas as well because of the revolution
yet the french revolution
you had the american revolution against
the british you had the french
revolution against the
the bourgeoisie right the elites and so
on
uh a very important philosopher in the
history of liberalism is immanuel kant
he you could argue really he was one of
the most important philosophers
you could make this argument in western
history you could make this argument
maybe right after aristotle or something
he's a very important figure
not only in liberal thought but in all
of western thor emmanuel kent
and he gave some contributions as well
as you can see here this is a time
where it's kind of the industrial
revolution things are starting to change
here
you know steam changes trains were being
invented and so on
so he was at a time where there was
technological developments and so on
then you had john stuart mill who was
around in the victorian era
this guy is important in liberalism and
generally because a lot of the
dominant ethics that we have today
especially in social
circles are based on his ideas by the
way
and he was way to use a colonial you
know postcolonial term
beyond his time in the sense that he was
for universal suffrage for both men and
women which we don't have a problem with
as muslims by the way just in case
anyone tries to chuck something at me
right but he was you know the prophet
muhammad by the way and islam they gave
you know the muslims gave baya men and
women gave bayer
1400 years ago that's just an
interesting kind of tangential point
there
we're in the year what 2000 what we're
now 2018 or 19. now
i forget nine times yeah so this was
about 100 years
ago that women could both men and women
can vote
right 100 years ago that's when you know
in in in the uk
at least in in um in canada it was 1917
but he was beyond this time in that
perspective if you wrote a treatise on
uh on women and women's kind of
uh universal suffrage and other kind of
things
the most important thing that you could
probably pluck out of his philosophy
which is very important
is the harm principle and you'll find
that this is the logic
that almost everyone uses you know to
justify whatever moral they want to
justify
and the harm principle going back to our
hedonistic principle now
the hedonistic principle was what that
you are you want to
you want to minimize pain and maximize
what
pleasure okay so everyone's with me yeah
so obviously this guy called jeremy
bentham came along and said but hold on
he said yeah we want to maximize the
amount as much
pleasure as possible and as possible
generally yeah
so you had scenarios like you know a
gang grape scenario so if you have ten
men and one woman
and they all want to enjoy themselves so
they can all yeah exploit the woman
this was the issue with utilitarianism
so
john stuart mill came along and said
there's a problem with utilitarianism
which is that it allows this kind of
infringement of human rights
or he didn't really refer to as human
rights as we'll come to know but on
individual liberties and so you can do
whatever you want to do
so long as you don't harm anyone else
this is the harm principle
let's say one more time you can do
whatever you want to do
so long as you don't harm anyone so now
if you're asked
it's a bit of controversial topic but if
you ask why is homosexuality
why should it be or any kind of thing
right not just homosexuality any
non-normative sexual practice any
non-normative sexual practice should it
be allowed
so a liberal would should answer at
least so long as it doesn't harm anyone
else
it should be allowed
have you heard this so obviously
those religious people who were arguing
against for example homosexuality
were saying that
it's not natural and all those kind of
things yeah a liberal turns around and
says that's not the ethic that we're
dealing with right now
the ethic that we're dealing with is
that so long as it doesn't harm anyone
else
you can't get involved that's the ethic
okay if that's the ethic my question
would be
what about incest rights that's my
question because it's not really
something which is emphasized
now someone might argue that hold on
deform babies
you can have deformed baby coming out of
that situation
i would say hold on what if a father
and a son there's no babies going to
come out of that
actually or a brother and a brother
that's not something which liberals have
actually in my
estimation at least as a movement has
tried to
guarantee the rights of incest rights
even though it goes along
the same kind of principles as john
stuart millsand principle
right so there has been a kind of
favoring of
one kind of non-normative practice in
this case homosexuality
over other kinds of non-normative sexual
practices for example
incest and so on but this kind of the
reason for that is just simply because
homosexuals in the 60s and 70s or those
groups who represented them
had more of a chance and had more
success in being
able to mobilize social support
for their cause if there had been a
million
father brothers coming out together with
placards incest rights we love each
other
you know seriously i mean would they be
guaranteed the same rights in many of
the countries
which are liberal countries this is
illegal
this is illegal incest is illegal but
the question is why is it illegal it
doesn't go against
the harm principles they deform babies
but what if they're using contraception
what if his
two brothers brother and brother there's
no babies going to come out of that
seriously so there has been a double
standard in the way
even liberal principles have been
manipulated
in order to make cases
so if i've had lots of conversations you
can maybe see them on youtube
what i find problematic is the most
consistent answer by the way some of
them are just straightforward to say
you're right
if we're gonna off if we're gonna afford
rights for one
non-normative sexual practice like
homosexuality
we should afford it for all
non-normative sexual practices so long
as no harm is done
that's a consistent answer i would say
you know what you make
at least you're consistent but some
homosexuals
or other people who claim to represent
their interests actually
argued among along naturalistic lines
they said no it's not natural for
uh a brother and a brother to have sex
so why is it not who defines natural now
because you just told off that christian
guy
that he told him off when he said you're
what you're doing is not natural
so what gives you the right to determine
what's natural not natural
so a secondary explanation could be well
we're born gay and this is something
david hume referred to as the ought is
problem just because you're born let's
just say for the sake of argument i'm
not going to go into the genetics i'm
not a geneticist
let's say for the sake of arguing say
you're born gay no problem but just
because you are something
it doesn't mean you ought to be that
thing and there's no way
that any philosopher has been able to
solve this problem
david hume himself in his book inquiry
into moral ethics
he described the problem he said well
just because something is
the case it doesn't mean it ought to be
the case what if someone
is born with an incestuous gene does it
mean that they should be incestuous
what if someone is born with something
more pernicious than that
or you know in our estimation of course
you could argue
morals are relative frankly i mean who
is to make the judgment
however the point is the or is
distinction
is always going to be a problem for
someone who wants to say we're born that
way
so the problem is when now we're asked
okay
in islam let's be honest in islam
why is homosexuality a sin we say wait
hold on
why is that type particular type of
non-normative
sexual practice permitted on your world
view they say because the
the harm principle say okay well the
harm principle should apply to two
brothers having sex
and two sisters having if you want to
call it sex you can call it sex
whatever it may be right or even a
brother and a sister so long as some
kind of contraception is used and so on
and so forth
but you're not using that they are using
that
hats off to them well done you're being
morally consistent and you're being
in accordance with the harm principle if
you're not using that and you're giving
preferential treatment to one kind of
non non-normative sexual practice of
another frankly it doesn't even make
sense
so this is the last thing i'm going to
quickly touch upon
now and we've talked that we've kind of
touched upon the idea of some of the
questions we're asked as
let's say traditionalists or you know
conventional orthodox whatever you want
to call it muslims right
why this why that well the reason why
they're asking that question as we've
just discovered
is because they have a dominant ethic
which frankly
for the most part has not been
consistently used in western circles
is not predicated on anything which is
objective
you can't put any of that stuff under a
microscope all of those morals frankly
have not been
verified
so they don't really have a reason to
ask us any of those questions in the
first place
now when you when we talk about this
thing human rights
because now this is a guys this is
almost the trump card
if you want to knock out not trump
donald trump
if you want to knock out a muslim ask
them about human rights
ask them about freedom of expression and
speech what's the ruling on blasphemy
laws
what's the ruling and we'll talk about
this in detail in the next section
on apostasy law i'm going to bring this
up as the case study
what happens in an islamic state yes
what happens is isn't that
is it is there a death penalty there is
it will come to it
it's a bit of a suspense we'll talk
about it in the next session
but isn't that against human rights
let's say for the sake of argument yes
it's against human rights
all of the things that you mentioned and
other things
anything yes it's against human rights
but let's go back what is human rights
and outgrowth of
human rights is an outgrowth of this
shaky destabilized
liberalism which frankly has not been
substantiated in the first instance
so there's a problem there
so in history we're going to talk about
quickly i mean first of all this word
human rights it was not referred to as
human rights
until quite recently it was referred to
usually as natural rights
so even when people like jeremy bentham
was attacking it he called it nonsense
and stilts
because what natural rights how can you
prove it jeremy bentham the one who
talked about
utilitarianism the one who actually
taught the teacher of john stuart mill
and the one who was he inspired him in
many ways he called it nonsense on
stilts
but we'll come to that this is an
interesting thing there's the last slide
for today
um for this session and then we'll come
back and talk about the other things
the this is an interesting thing it's
called google engram you can use it to
see how much a word has been used in
literature
and if you can see here the word human
rights itself
only started to become popular
around 1948 and obviously that's when it
was written the
convention of human rights but before
that this term
human rights wasn't even in the common
vernacular
of either the academics or the
non-academics
so all of a sudden after the world war
ii after world war
ii this thing that you guys made up
frankly
called human rights which we're gonna
talk about
right we're gonna talk about human
rights this thing you guys made up
called human rights
which you insisted is universal with any
without any proof
is now being used to colonialize
to colonize this is
it's being used to spread the you know
liberalism by the sword
and that's the irony of it all so the
question is
to what extent are human rights
compatible with traditionalist islam
we're going to look at a case study and
we're going to be very straightforward
today guys
in the after the break we're going to
look at
some of the most controversial case
studies you can think about
the most controversial questions those
which i was talking about which
reference the punitive law of islam
those which reference for example the
had the hadood
the punishments in islam and we are
going to do a thorough
comparison inshallah between liberalism
and tradition as islam and what we're
going to uncover
on earth in my opinion is going to be
something which will put things
in perspective so i'll let you guys have
the break now
because the time is up and we'll see you
after the break
all right good
so um this is going to be the last part
of like the monologue if you like
you know and then after that we're gonna
try and create more interactivity
because it is important that we engage
with one another you might have
lots of questions i'm sure you do um and
so
just to kind of carry on from where we
pick up from where we left off
we talked about human rights as not
being a term that was commonly employed
um throughout the centuries frankly
right it wasn't really a term which was
goes all the way back to liberalism or
all the way back to for example the
ancient greeks or something like that
instead it's a term which
became very popular after 1948 that's
not to say it didn't exist
before 1940 a it did exist but it just
become much more popular because of
well because as you know the un which is
an organization which is
pretty much steered by united states of
america
and other allies took control of the un
and obviously they had the convention
and after that convention was put
forward it became part of the media
became part of academia and so on
but taking a step back now the question
is
because i mentioned and alluded to this
in the beginning
of this lecture we talked about some of
the mythologies that
liberalism is predicated on what did i
mean when i say liberalism is predicated
on mythology
now what i meant was this the state of
nature
the state of nature is a very important
part of liberalism
and it's mentioned by many different
scholars and thinkers
like john locke like thomas hobbes like
rousseau and others and
for instance thomas hobbes
talks about this hypothetical state
before human beings were contracted to
the state
so let's take a contemporary example we
live in the west for example you guys
live in holland i live in the uk
i'm born into you know that state you
guys many of you
uh except for the illegal immigrants i'm
sure
which is the majority no
we're born here right so you so you come
or you're born here or you decide to
come over
through ship or whoever you guys did
right
yes you decide to come over here
and when you come over here what are you
obliged by the law the universal law
in other words you have to obey the law
of the land you know
it's a straightforward thing but the
question is who gave the government the
power in the first place
who gave government the power in the
first place so liberal theory would
suggest
that there was a state of nature
there was a primordial if you like say
of nature
and then we contracted to
a sovereign or a representative or a
power
now when did this take place when did
this thing take place where there was
man against man
whether it was a brutish poor and short
thing it never actually historically
took place at all
this is a fake history and it was made
this is mythology this story this
fiction frankly this was made up
it wasn't a scientific investigation
that was done
it wasn't historical records that were
retrieved
it was simply a story a bedtime story a
fairy tale
seriously i mean this is what it's
predicated on
thomas hobbs john locke and others
this they talked about a time a pre
maybe a prehistoric time or a
pre-government time where people were
fighting each other
and so they needed to give up some of
their rights in order to allow
the sovereign master to come and protect
them
and all of the subsequent generations of
people
would be subsequently contracted to that
government
even if they didn't consent to it
because we
living in a country we didn't say we
consent to there being a government
we consent to their being you know a
representative that's gonna
make law on our behalf sometimes you
have voting yes
but it's not we didn't even consent to
the system of government
so how do we justify from a liberal
perspective that there is a government
it's this idea which we're going to come
on to of social contract
but the primordial state
is a story it's a bedtime fiction
it's fake it really is fake now the
story
is different depending on which
philosopher talks about it so for
example kent he says all mankind
who will but consult it that being all
equal and independent no one ought to
harm another in his life liberty or
possessions
so in the primordial state for for locke
he he envisaged
that there were some rights that ought
to be protected in the first instance
hobbes saw it more about man against man
but
both made up the story that there was a
time
or there ought to have been a time this
is hypothetical
metaphysical mythological
fictitious thing that happened
where we were all human beings were all
like in the jungle if you like of life
and we're all fighting each other and we
needed some
leader to come that we could con consult
with or contract with
in order to stop the chaos and the
anarchy that's the story
so humans initially have rights
of liberty lockwood argue and property
hobbs would disagree with him but both
have made up the story it's a fake story
now the social contract
was required now and
the social contract
we've already mentioned is
this contract that human beings took
when they were in the state of fighting
each other in the state of nature
they took this contract with the
sovereign some kind of
leader maybe the the sovereign had power
military power
maybe they were able to grant protection
whatever it may be there was a contract
subhanallah this is actually quite
similar to islamic theology
because we also believe in a contract as
well you know that
you know and it's in the quran but we
believe our contract was
with allah so we were contracted with
allah
they believe we were contracted with an
imaginary
fake figure in fact the book that
hobbs talked about is called de la vicen
it's called the levison what is the
levison it's a monster
it's a monster creature it's a it's a
fake like a
something sci-fi like a sci-fi image
tell me if this is not mythology why is
it not mythology is it because the white
man wrote it down
be honest with yourselves seriously is
it because it's secular
it's pure mythology
and there's nothing to justify it
whatsoever but as muslims we believe in
a contract
right with allah where allah says in the
quran
allah took the message the contract with
adam with the children of adam
you know uh
their back you know and he said allah
become he said are we not your
am i not your lords and your master
we said yes so for us as muslims we was
we were contracted to allah
for the liberal we were contracted to
some imaginary figure
which didn't really exist even according
to them if you ask any liberal today
do you believe in this uh this thing no
we don't believe it so they have a
mythology as well
we don't have a mythology we would say
we can justify the existence of god
from first principles which is a
different conversation for a different
time
all right so what are the entailments of
social contract and this is a key point
here in the discussion
because we talked about human rights and
some of the questions we're asked as
muslims relate to fundamental human
rights
so for example equality of men and women
this is
by the way according to what strand of
feminism second wave feminism
third wave feminism you know first wave
feminism even
what do we mean by equality according to
who's feminism is it the eurocentric
understanding of feminism
is that an african feminism is it a
middle eastern
that's a different discussion but they
say also that we have to have
freedom of expression of whatever
religious belief you want
to what extent though because obviously
society even in this country and other
countries has decided that there are
certain kinds of things which can't
exist which jeopardize security and so
on
so the question is when now we've come
out of the state of nature from a
liberal perspective we've come
out of the state state of nature and
we're socially contracted
to this representative which in modern
parlance would be referred to as
government right
when we're now where we're tied to such
representative
the question is what are
the things this representative can do on
our behalf
this is a key thing and i want everyone
to remember this right
this is something which immanuel kant
which we said already was one of the
biggest philosophers in all of liberal
history but
not only that but one of the biggest
philosophy of all the western history
he basically says i'm not going to read
this whole thing you can you can kind of
read it yourself
he basically says that if the supreme
sovereign this socially contracted thing
or body or government or whatever it is
they can that has pretty much ultimate
authority
even if he decides to kill you or kill
some people or
jail some people or hurt some people
there's a there's a hadith inside muslim
that says which some people make fun of
that you know if you've got to be
obedient to the leader even if he whips
your back
or takes your money obviously there's
such a big discussion on this we're not
having in that discussion but
this is the same kind of thing in
liberal theory
so in liberal theory it's conceivable
that there is a law which so
limits which so limits
human freedoms so as to allow
someone to be killed as a result and
john locke says
in one of his books i think it's the two
truths of government
he says if someone is commanded to stand
in the face of a cannon if a soldier is
commanded
to stand in the face of a cannon
yes in other words a blowing cannon he
should do it
and it's not illegal for someone to do
that which is kind of like suicide
bombing by the way
think about that no seriously it's this
what is that you know tell me what that
is
standing in the face of a cannon is
destroying yourself it's killing
yourself suicide
so according to john locke and by the
way also according to john rules
who says that you can kill innocents by
the way this is what he says
he says you can kill innocents in war
it's just war you can get you can target
the innocent
not collateral damage no you can target
them
so you can not only be subject to a
suicide type scenario
according to john locke but all the way
through to john rules who said
you not only can be subject to such
scenario but you can subject
others to such scenario as well in other
words you can kill children
if it goes back to the social contract
and if it goes back to the
mandated legitimate sovereign leader who
we have been socially contracted to
in this mythological state of nature
bearing that in mind the question now is
what's the relevance of this and
apostasy well you know the liberal would
ask what is this thing
that you guys have in your old books of
of jurisprudence and i said in the
beginning of the lecture
that when i describe i'll be defining
what islamic traditionalism is so i'll
do it quickly now
islamic traditionalism to me is a
jurisprudential understanding of islam
for example through the four schools of
thor in sunni islam
for example right so that's my
understanding of
islamic traditionalism so obviously if
you open a book of islamic
law which is like a classical book
and you go to maybe the you know kitabul
jinayat or something like that
you might see this the punishment of
apostasy
and you'll see that some of those
scholars will say the one who changes
his religion
you know they should be killed in an
islamic state
and you think wait a minute doesn't this
strongly oppose human rights and on the
face of it it
does strongly oppose human rights and
this is not
on the face of it prima facie what we
believe in anyway
this is and deconsexualized
understanding of islamic law and i'll
explain that in a second
but what's interesting is this so long
as something is justified through a
social contract
on liberalism look what john locke is
saying
john locke who is the founding father of
liberalism
says that there can be
an apostasy law
wait a minute what does he say he says
the first is those of who
being initiated in the mosaic right he's
talking about the jewish
states or jewish states and made
citizens of that commonwealth did
afterwards apostasize means become
from the worship of the god of israel
these were preceded against
as traitors and rebels guilty of no
less than high treason listen to this
no less than high treason for the
commonwealth
of the jews different in that from all
others was an absolute theocracy
nor was there or could there be any
difference between that
and the commonwealth of the church now
what does this mean what's he trying to
say
he's saying because the the
the state of the jews is predicated
on your contracting with god
and you're being jewish in the first
instance
that it's justifiable on liberalism
listen to this carefully it's
justifiable on
liberalism from this social contract
understanding
that if someone publicly says i'm not a
jew anymore
for the state to say come hold here come
here we're going to
execute you now is that what the quran
says
the quran doesn't make this kind of
articulation by the way
this is what john locke says who is the
founding father of liberalism
so how conceivable is it
how conceivable is there on liberalism
that these laws can be put in place it
is
fully conceivable in principle now one
could argue
that was john locke that was 300 years
ago
we're no longer looking at luck my
argument is not about
john locke he is looking at the
conceivability
through the principles of liberalism
i am saying because the principles of
liberalism through social contract
allow such possibilities you cannot
argue that liberalism
is against a public apostasy law
which would entail a death of a person
you cannot argue that it's impossible to
argue that you could argue as a liberal
i'm not really
you know in tune with that and i think
it ought not to be
but if a country decides if a country
decides for example
that this country is not a secular
country not this country obviously is
but we're talking about a country like
you know a jewish
state not talking about israel that's a
different discussion
but if it decides okay this is not we're
not our social contract is not a secular
one
it's a theocracy of some sort let's say
for the sake of arguing
or is something which is predicated on
religious scriptures
if that's the case the question is how
illiberal is it on social
contractarianism
to have such law john locke answers in
fact
this is not illiberal at all and not
only would john locke say that
emmanuel kent would say that i've seen
manuscripts of john stuart mill saying
that
it's quite consistent so
the question now is what does islam have
to say about that
but before i go into that question about
apostasy in islam
there's an argument i want to make and
the main argument is articulated
here because this is part of my book
i've actually written a book here it's
coming out
maybe the end of the year yes yes i've
been doing the research
by the way this is not something i just
whipped up this i've spoken to a lot of
academics about this
all right my main argument liberalism or
liberalization efforts
are epistemologically fruitless
if they are predicated on the assumption
that such liberalization
necessarily entails more freedom from
government
interventionism in cases which relate to
administration of the death penalty for
non-allegiance to a state now that's a
very long-winded statement
but you have to be careful with
academics what i'm saying is
there is something similar between
for example that which is referred to as
which is the what is referred to as the
punishment for apostasy
and treason and the common denominator
is
non-allegiance to a state so for example
if you look at the american constitution
if my memory serves me correctly i think
article 3 talks about
the treason it's a clause on treason
treason clause
and basically what it says is the future
of non-allegiance
different states have different rules in
america it could be punishable and
has been punishable by death and by the
way
what's interesting is as a side note in
terms of
actual case study examples you'll find
that america has conducted many
extrajudicial
killings outside of obviously the
parameters of the judiciary as you know
for example
many of you may have heard of anwar
al-awlaki yes
his son was killed his name is abdul
rahman al-awlaki
and his daughter was also killed they
were kids by the way
they were killed by a drone attack on
them yes
them why because the american government
were afraid
because okay their father is a radical
the child will also grow up to be
a radical right so they literally sent
little drones
to kill the kids now that wasn't those
kids didn't
deserve to be killed and no moreover
they didn't even stand trial
if that was possible for a child to
stand trial at the age of six years old
or whatever it may have been anyway
so the question of extrajudicial killing
is something completely different anyway
i'm talking about when the treason law
itself has been implemented and what's
interesting if you look at
constitutional law in america
is that those defendants who are subject
to such
encroachments from the military
establishment in america
actually try and get the treason law to
be enacted on them in other words they
try and
a lot of them argue that we want to be
tried in accordance with the treason law
because they know they have more chance
of being not killed for example
in in that case but there have been
those extra
judicial killings now that's something
else the point is this it's conceivable
principally
it is conceivable principally that a
government because it
deems you as non-ally now
you're no longer a citizen depriving you
of your citizenship and so on
they can make a subsequent decision to
kill you
and it has been done but it's just been
named something else
this is the point now the truth is this
in islam
you have to first ask what is apostasy
and what is treason
right now who gets to define treason now
someone might argue treason is this and
they'll go online and you know this
pseudo-intellectual approach oh treason
means this listen spare your white man
definitions
keep them to yourself seriously who
wrote the dictionary
who was it was it someone who we all
agreed this is the authority yes let him
be the one no come on be let's be honest
oxford dictionary webster dictionary no
it wasn't something which we all
as humankind decided yes this is no no
vernacular definitions from the
dictionary are fruitless to me
you can't use a secular definition
impose it on a religious
framework and explain try and explain
things that way
treason is defined differently yes
because you have a secular framework
versus a religious one why should you
impose a secular framework on a
religious one
as much as why would you ex impose a
religious one on a secular one
they both have two different standards
right
however the principle of non-allegiance
is the same so in other words really and
truly what is the common denominator
when a state deems that you're no longer
allied now here's the point
is it to do with what you believe now i
would
put to you submit to everyone here today
that it's not to do with what you
believe and the evidence is not like
that there's no compulsion in religion
there is that that's for the muslims
by the way that verse by jamaa is for
the non-muslims there's no compulsion in
religion
chapter 2 verse 256 means you can't
force a non-muslim to become muslim
but what about meaning
where it says it's not from a man or a
woman who's a muslim or a mukmin
that when allah and his messenger decide
something that they have any choice in
the matter
the point is this even then it's not to
do with belief
and it's conceivable and possible for
someone to lose faith in their religion
as a muslim in an islamic governed
government state or whatever you want to
call it i'm not talking about those
things which exist
but it's conceivable and they would have
no repercussion whatsoever
it's not to do what's the evidence for
that two pieces of evidence
one of them is the the list of hadith
had a list of people who are unafraid
who does not believe really in islam he
does not believe in islam
that's the true understanding of munich
yes he might walk around in society and
not necessarily publicate
that he's left islam but he does not
disbelieve in he doesn't believe in
islam that list
even though muslims were aware that
those people were not muslims
they didn't kill those individuals
because there was no rupture of the
social contract there
in other words it's conceivable now if
someone in the west becomes
non-muslim and they were muslim we're
not going to say go and kill that
individual no way
this is an understanding of islam which
is orientalist
decontextualizing completely wrong in my
opinion there's no way you can do that
because there was no contract between
you and that person that okay you are
now
allied to that state in that way there's
no state in fact the state here
says you can do whatever you want and
you can have whatever belief you want so
in fact their contract is different to
your contract the quran says
those all you who believe fulfill the
contract so in other words there is no
contract there there has to be a
contract you have to be under an islamic
and you have to have agreed to the terms
if those conditions are not met
then we can't say there's any going to
be any ramification
now another point is this is that you
have and this is one of the final points
i'm going to make
is that you have another example and
this is one of the biggest
hadith in sahih bukhari it's in kitab
the book of conditions and then you have
a discussion between prophet muhammed
and and the quraysh was saying if
listen to this carefully if
your people in in your state become
non-muslim
bring them back to us do you agree to
those terms and he agreed to those terms
say that one more time he said if people
in your state become non-muslim
under this contract that we have now
bring those guys who have left islam
apostated back to us he said no problem
he agreed to those conditions
meaning what really this what this means
is that it's totally conceivable
both on islam and liberalism for there
to be some kind of social contract which
would bind somebody
to a state of being now
even if they decide to change their
religion it's conceivable on both
liberalism and islam
that it's not a problem and it's
conceivable on both liberalism and islam
that it could have ramifications
depending upon how it's perceived by the
state
now next
the reason why the the topic today
was referred to as liberalism as
religion and this is a really
interesting quote
i'm going to read it out it says
theories of modernization are not
scientific hypotheses
but theodicies narratives of providence
and redemption
presented in the jargon of social
science
what we're saying is that liberalism the
reason why it's been able to have this
perceived epistemological upper hand on
the religious narrative not just the
islamic one
it's because it seems like you're
speaking scientifically when you're
talking about secular ideology
what we've been able to show today
ladies and gentlemen is that that is not
the case
and that the the first principles of
liberalism are
unfounded unsubstantiated unproven
we've also been able to show ladies and
gentlemen that actually
not only are the first principles
unproven but a lot of them are based on
mythology fiction
stories and so on
and so to favor that kind of a narrative
over and above the islamic one
or any other religious narrative for
that matter is frankly
academically unfair in the first
instance
epistemologically unjustified in the
first instance
philosophically unjust frankly you can't
do that
and ask us questions so before any
questions are asked
from a person who claims to be a liberal
who might be now thinking that they have
found the ultimate truth
how can you prove liberalism as an
objective moral standard number one
from a scientific perspective or
otherwise or from a rational first
principle perspective
number two why do you expect us to
believe in your myth
why even even your philosophers that
propounded that myth
didn't believe in it fully themselves
they didn't conduct any scientific
experiments
number three do you not realize that
it's as
conceivable on a contractarian
understanding of liberalism
to have as much punitive law
as could conceivably be the case in an
islamic state with all of the punitive
laws being implemented
so if that is the case what do you have
to offer us
what is modernization why should we be
like you
what have you got for us the answer is
really you have nothing for
us sorry to say i need to be blunt you
have nothing to offer
liberalism has nothing to offer islam
that's the answer
it's there's nothing there for us
everything that's conceivable in
liberalism
can also be potentially conceivable in
islam and vice versa
in terms of punitive laws and so on so
what's the issue
now they'll say human rights human
rights and i'm going to say this once
and everyone should remember it
they human rights is a metaphysical
construct
which cannot be actualized in the real
world it's impossible to have an
actualization
of human rights with the existence of
social contracts you can never have
ultimate freedom of anything
that's nonsense on stilts as jeremy
bentham said it's impossible
now the answer is this that liberals
will say
we define the extent to which freedom of
speech expression and so on thought and
religion should be exercised in the
state
in accordance with democracy or this or
that or the other
but those things themselves are
problematic because they number one
could be in conflict of liberalism
and number two could bring out results
like hitler
which had you know retrospectively
everyone looks back and says how immoral
was he
in sum therefore what i want to say is
the question needs to be questioned
whenever they ask you a question which
is predicated on human rights
you should say no thank you you have to
first
justify yourself the last thing here
i've got
sorry it's okay for me to go over a
little bit
okay is this is there is an orientalism
here
by the way orientalism is not just a
book that edward side wrote
which places the east as the subject of
investigation
the abject the other but it's a kind of
orientalism which
actually also exists in liberal
discourse so what many liberal
orientalists and progressive muslims
groups attempt to do
is demonstrate the extent to which the
or punitive laws refer to in the
traditionalist discourse are totally
aberrational and therefore
unacceptable in the context of human
rights and liberalism in particular
from this abduction muslim minorities in
the west who have no intention of
bringing to life such abstract rulings
are further abject to social imagination
of large sways of the majority of
populists in other words
real and truly all of those punitive
laws of islam have nothing to do with
the muslim
minority existence in the west we have
no
intention whatsoever of implementing
any of the punitive laws in the western
world but those laws
are used as an ammunition against a
minority
which produces an irony frankly
the irony is use those things to instill
fear in the majority
in order for you to juxtapose yourself
or define yourself against
the muslim minority and that is frankly
a tyranny of the majority type logic
which liberalism itself came to dismiss
irony it's an irony almost all liberal
thinkers talked about tyranny of the
majority
now you have this guy what's his name
gates
what's his first name again i don't care
about his name
you know wilder whatever his name he's
talking about
attacks for women wearing headscarf in
this this is against
liberalism because it is frankly it
doesn't understand that when you have a
law in a liberal state it has to be
consistent to all people he's not even
liberal
his part is called the freedom party you
should take this ammunition
and it's not physical ammunition no take
the
it's intellectual bullets and shoot this
guy and others
physically not not physically not
feeling
intellectually where should i am
so i'll end with does that
come like i can open up for questions
and analysis
give me this thing yes now you can stay
on there
so q a um guys about the questions
please no fatawa i love it i know we
love fatawa
last year two years ago we were i was at
medina expo and we had a two hour
lecture about community building
first question that comes in is isla
guys please keep it at the subject and
challenge muhammad hijab a bit okay i
want to see him sweat on his forehead
okay so who's got the first question
assalamu alaikum brother thanks for your
presentation
i have a question about your debating
approach
you told us about the harm principle
and also so basically
more enjoyment or what's the word
exactly more enjoyment less harm
and more pleasure that's the word
exactly
after that you also used another example
um
saying that if you don't harm at least
people saying that if you don't harm the
other
person then it's okay you can do
whatever you want and in your debate
you approach people for example by
saying
what about incestual relationships
but what i was thinking is suppose the
other person
you convince the other person and the
other person turns around and says
you know what i'm actually for brother
and brother
or sister and sister relationships be
then going towards a
society that's even more uh
you know there's more fitnah in the
society so we don't actually
at least i don't like we don't want that
i assume
so is is that the right approach to go
around it i can see
i can see you're concerned i could
definitely see it
um i think it's important to show people
sometimes the inconsistencies if someone
turns around and says
you know i'm for that thing i'm full
brother and brother having
intercourse with one another or sister
and sister and so on
then to be honest with you they're being
uh consistent with their moral and their
ethic
right but my issue is not with those
individuals that are being consistent
with their ethic my issue issues with
those individuals are not being
consistent with their ethic
they would allow one kind of
non-normative practice and not another
now
is this what i think underlying this
concern is
doesn't this bring people now closer to
maybe legalizing incest in certain
countries and so on
well to be honest with you my friend
i'll be honest you know even if they
didn't
legalize it it would still be happening
would just be more socially acceptable
or unacceptable
that's that's the only thing i think
that incest is actually happening it's
just socially unacceptable
and from islamic perspective there is a
reason for that which is the fitra the
fitra
is the innate disposition which
recognizes certain moral things as
abhorren
naturally right and we would use that
same argument with anything which is
non-normative and non-compliance with
the quran by the way not just
incest so if we can get them to kind of
reflect
using this kind of thought experiment or
this you know method of debate whatever
you want to call it
sometimes it activates the fitra and
that's that's the
if you like the objective of of doing
that not not necessarily because i'm
going to go outside of 10 downing street
or
the was it the hague here i don't know
where it is or whether you guys have
parliament and say you know brother and
sister should really
i'm not gonna i'm not a campaigner for
that just you know to be clear
but yeah i see your concern i think it
is a bit of a double-edged thought
but we have to do we have to do it you
know sometimes the
the advantages outweigh the
disadvantages okay
thank you very much okay next question
who wants to
see thank you very much
my brother with your presentation
but one thing is very important in at
this moment
you talk about john locke and
aman merkant dear metaphysic
a person and he has done a lot of things
to
recognize god in the community
emmanuel kant and about 12 years he
researched about that that means after
a very dark period
we have a renaissance period in european
country
my question is now the liberalism is a
fact that we have to compare with islam
law how you can compute it that
islam can be practicized in liberalism
all
regularism can have effect in islam
that is a sort of reconciliation that we
can
justify and also bring the people
for a sort of peace
community and it will be very useful for
the
future of the new generation
[Music]
okay thank you uh emmanuel in in
critique of pure reason
he was criticizing the cosmological
argument it's difficult to know where he
stands religiously by the way i think he
there's a good case of him being an
atheist and to be honest because he
criticizes the arguments for god's
existence
but it doesn't mean just because he
criticizes them that he doesn't believe
in god
um so it's difficult i think scholars
have struggled with the what is
emmanuel cancer religious background
that's a question i'll leave open
but in regards to your second question i
think you're absolutely right i think
there should be an accommodationist
approach
um and that accommodationist approach is
a recognition by both muslim communities
and majority for example non-muslim
communities
that actually where muslims are
minorities yes they will
they must be subject to the law of
whatever land they're in and that's by
the way part and parcel of what they
believe in
so even so you cannot impose a law which
is islamic on a liberal state
but what liberals must understand is
that they cannot impose
a law which is liberal anti-islamic in
an islamic state as well
and that is a fair approach i believe
and if that is understood
then this colonial attitude of or we've
got the
right metaphysic and you don't have the
right metaphysic that can start to be
put aside and we start realizing that
actually okay
we have our way and you have your way
but when there's this approach which
actually is linked very strongly with
the colonial
um you know the colonial empire of the
hegemonic west at the moment
and pre and in the maybe last 200 300
400 years
with slavery and all that stuff it
becomes more problematic because it
becomes sanctimony western sanctimony oh
you should be like us basically as if
god made the world in
western image so that is i think where
the problem is well we have to challenge
it
but there is a truth there if we're
living in western countries we have to
abide
by western law so long as that law does
not
arbitrarily discriminate against muslims
like the kind of laws we're seeing
unfortunately being passed in this
country with the niqab ban for example
or in france with you know head covering
being
taken off which clearly is is targeted
against one community over
and above all other communities which is
against liberalism
it's not only just against islam but
it's absolutely against liberalism
because it destroys the um arbitrariness
of
law and it destroys the principle of
you know trying to look after a minority
rather than tyranny of the majority
so we have to remind them of their own
principles sometimes as well
maybe a sister now come on be feminist
we've been very critical tonight about
concepts like democracy
secularism human rights and
you've just in continuation with the
previous question
how can we see the rule of islam the
sharia basically let's name things as it
is
how can be fit within the the laws that
we have nowadays
in western countries or in any country
whatsoever and that they apply
secularism
and you said we should remind the white
men
how how we as muslims um
prefer to live which like according to
which laws
but the question is as i said we've been
very critical
the self-criticism is how we as muslims
should remind them and what should we do
like
to be a positive and active part in this
kind of
discussion or procedure to reach that
point
i think you're right you're absolutely
right we should be introspective
but introspection comes after uh the
insurance of protection
so black people in the united states
couldn't start saying we're gonna
you know attack our own community in the
1960s and be introspective
unless they first established themselves
as a community
we're able to secure certain civil
rights and then we can have discussions
about how to fix things within our own
house
but if we're not being given and this is
the issue if we're not being given
equal treatment you know through this
kind of unarbitrary law that's the
starting point we have to start with
that first
once that conversation is done or during
meanwhile we can also talk about
like you said how we should be you're
absolutely right positively contributing
through charity and through community
work and through
you know i'm not gonna use the word
integration by the way but through
economic contribution to a state which
doesn't jeopardize any of our principles
so
i think these are parallel conversations
we can have at the same time
but we should make a focus uh of the
discussion
our own rights otherwise they're going
to tell us what our rights ought to be
i think that should be a focus
you started off with some epistemology
and um so lately i was
uh reading some books of philosophy some
skeptic works
about knowing things and i read this
skeptic paradox and
i don't know if you've heard of it any
about knowing whether we have hands
no i haven't read this robert nozick
george immortal oh robert nozick is a
liberal himself
yes okay go ahead so the paradox goes as
this
i know that i have hands yeah i don't
know that i'm not a brain in a vet
if i do not know uh that i'm not in
brain in a vet i do not know if i that i
have hands
so i read a internalistic
approach to on this internalist answer
externalist answer
but they could not really convince me so
i would
like to ask you how would you answer
this paradox i don't know paradoxes are
unanswerable by
nature you know i mean to be honest with
you i can give you the i can give you 20
paradoxes it's the whole point of a
paradox is that many of them are
unanswerable right
but are they implement are they
physically relevant to the real world
so a lot of a lot for example let me
give you another paradox which
a lot of you might have heard right that
and this relates to theology
so can god create a rock so heavy that
he can self can't
lift yeah and after thinking about this
for a long time
here's my answer right the existence of
such a rock would disprove god's
existence
because god by his definition is you
know it's an omnipotent he's
all powerful so certain things that god
does
that if he does he stops being god like
he becomes a man or starts having
limitations or something like that or
weaknesses
so in other words these paradoxes and
this is something which hopefully will
help you with every single paradox out
there
some of them are problematic in
semantics
in other words the way you're phrasing
the question has no
material relevance in the real world it
does it's not possible it's like saying
can god create a square and then change
it can god create a squared circle for
example right
can no but but that such a thing squared
circle concept
is not an applicable one to the real
world and most paradoxes are like that
the paradox itself is not applicable in
a cosmological reality
so it's only um it's only something
which can be said
by syntax but cannot be shown
by physical necessity so all of the
paradoxes of the world almost all of
them can be solved like that
even the mathematical ones but in terms
of the actual
physical ones and you know there's
there's a book on the guy called
jim jimmy uh khalili i think he wrote a
book on paradoxes
and you know jimmy kalili he wrote a
book on like
i don't know 100 paradoxes in there and
the answer is the same usually the
paradox can be solved by saying
that these things are not implementable
in the real world they're not physically
tangible there you can't
you can't engage with them really
no more paradoxes everybody's confused
[Laughter]
i wrote down my question to briefly ask
it
you stated liberalism has nothing to
offer
islam and as a believer i am convinced
about the moral
superiority of islam but i can imagine
that
liberals might think where are the
examples of a
sound peaceful economically and socially
healthy community in islam
so the lack of good practices whereas
there are plenty of them
in western liberal countries how would
you reply to this question
the quran says
you know there's a there's an
interesting book called the rise and
fall of great empires the quran says
that these are the days which we
alternate between the people in the
thousand four hundred years of islam's
civilized i'm not gonna say
civilizational existence but certainly
in terms of its timeline
you'll find that there were times where
it was if not the superpower one of the
superpowers of the world
you know so if you look at for example
the abbasid empire
that is an example it's a historical
example of
a thriving you know civilization which
incorporated different
parts of the world and where people you
know dealt with intellection if you like
civilizationally in the libraries of
baghdad
if you look at for instance the example
of
spain you know that's a very big example
you had so many a plethora of scholars
coming out there
so so much so that some people even said
that
that movement started the renaissance in
the west
don't forget the west even despite the
fact that liberalism existed within it
for many years was not in fact in that
peaceful state of existence that you
think it was in
i mean the european dark ages which many
historians say
started from about 4 10 when for
historical
purposes they say the anglo-saxons
came into britain up until about you
know
maybe about 1400s or something you know
that was the european decade a thousand
years of
you know a lack of you know substantive
um you know contribution given from the
west so this narrative is problematic
islam has probably more examples than
any other civilization
if you look in a historical timeline of
multiculturalism number one because
frankly
liberalism coexisted with slavery it
coexisted with
racism it co-existed with colonialism
and
in fact it was spread by colonialism
napoleon
he spread liberalism by the sword he was
referred to as a liberal dictator
you know don't forget he was a liberal
after the you know the french revolution
so this narrative is really problematic
it really really is problematic
that you know racism was justified up
until the late 19th century in america
where you literally had slaves
which were black and the reason for them
being black slaves was
was was was actually given reason to
through liberal frameworks a social
contract and all those things
so this thing here that we're talking
about is not as black and white as many
people think
that's why the quran gives us a formula
it says look at those
people that came allah come that they
came before you
you know ken they were stronger than you
in strength
and there's many different ending of
that verses in the part of the quran so
in other words
look at the the civilizations that have
risen and
fell yeah and realize that actually this
is less to do with ideology and more to
do with
all other things military success
geopolitical circumstances
you know even natural resources why did
the
industrial revolution happen in 1760 in
in england
and not in india is it because you know
the english people were more clever and
you know how to deal with
no it's because there was a
concentration of coal in britain which
they could use to power
you know steam trains and so on so a lot
of it these things are you can't
correlate it's a false thing it's a
fallacy to think
i'm not saying you're doing the fallacy
by the way i'm just saying it's a
fallacy thing that correlation equals
causation
there are a plethora of different
contributing factors if we look at that
in all in totality we realize
that the situation is way more nuanced
than we think
maybe a question on that side yes thank
you bismillah
salaam alaikum um my question
maybe inshallah fits you very well
because the question was also a bit
a little bit of political issues um
today i came from austria vienna and my
question is
because of this area yeah many people
are very feared is it
it's a double question actually many
people are very feared about something
like a
great replacement which happens because
of increasing of muslim population in
central europe probably and my question
is
many people fear about this great
replacement
and this affects muslims too worldwide
you
know my question is how to handle these
um wrong narratives because it's
very um it touches many people the
people in europe and they also fear
islam will less liberate them
so to say so how what is your
recommendation on that topic
i think you guys are doing a great job
by the way in austria because he's got
an organization
you know it's called iman isn't it
that's great yes it's a it's a great
organization that's what we should be
doing we should be
raising our voices and making the
arguments and if we don't do it
that it's going to be the argument is
going to be put on us and i think what
you guys are doing in austria
knowing the social context because me
being from britain
and there's only so much i can offer
everyone else you know people in
specific contexts
you know must do their own homework look
at the social and legal context
and deal with the issues at hand you
know so the kind of work you're doing
is exactly what needs to be done and
sometimes it's just a matter
of like the sister was talking about
kind of self-reflection and things like
that and being contributive
to society literally mixing with people
because pure research has shown us
that the most racist or islamophobic
societies are the ones
which have the least interaction with
muslims you know so if we go and this
country is a little bit of an odd case
because you've got 20 million people but
you've somehow got this
guy in this far right thing with so many
seats in parliament
it's quite an odd situation in western
europe to have that many
you know seats so what i would say is we
need to go out to the areas where
there is not as many muslims we need to
with these are the areas we need to go
into
we need to tap those areas we need to
show these people as sad as it sounds
that we're actually human beings
you know i mean as sad as it sounds
because they don't believe that
you know and and really they don't
because if you look at what they've done
and
how dehumanization works it starts off
with this other rising and it ends out
it finishes off it plays out until
someone is killed
and you know one of my good friends his
name is sharif
where i did a podcast with as well he's
doing his phd
on on dehumanization and what he was
talking to me about
was how drones in particular are being
used because drones if you look at
how many how they're this little you
know remote control
almost game-like you know things where
you can go and kill someone when someone
is far away from
someone this is his conclusion if you
like if the further away you are of
someone
the easier it is to conceive of
killing them for your game it's not
they're not human it's difficult
if you see a human right in front of you
the closer we become to them right
the easier it is for them to realize
that we're human beings and
unfortunately what is happening is
there is a steady process of
dehumanization which we need to close
the gap of
by actually being active members like
the sisters were saying in society not
just concentrating in one area
there needs to be groups of people that
literally reach out to those communities
where demographics are homogenous if
you're like oh there's lots of white
people
and no one else that's the most these
are the most dangerous areas
just to let you know because these are
the areas where people are most likely
to have the worst opinion of you
not just a view of all other you know
based on research
and statistics on all other you know
racial groups now that's the
generalization
but for the most part that's what the
research directs us to
we need to go into those areas tap them
talk to people show them we're human
and keep doing the kind of stuff you're
doing man i got a hand over here
yes did you come all the way from vienna
for this event
we'll come back to vienna we'll go to
you as well listen at least i'll try and
do that
yeah i totally agree that dialogue is
needed
but i have a question uh for you i'm not
talking about
liberalism i don't know either if i'm
christian i'm uh
but a liberalist i don't know but i'm uh
i'm in favor of human rights and i also
have a muslim friend who
who wrote an article about
yes that human rights and
islam yes are really compatible yes
don't you think that for a dialogue
between muslims and non-muslims in this
country
yeah uh human the the the statement of
human rights is a good basis
yeah i agree and i i agree that
they are both myths in in the way you
that's not no no i i totally agree with
your sentiment i think you've asked a
very good question and a very pertinent
one to the discourse and i thank you for
your contribution definitely correct
um the issue of course is of one of
definitions right
so who gets to define exactly what human
rights are how they should be
implemented
and who should implement them because
going back to emmanuel kan he believes
in something called
this philosopher and this is enacted by
the way in the u.n it's called
cosmopolitanism that's a big word what
does it mean it means that there are
these universal laws
which have to be implemented because if
you have you imagine if you have a world
state
right you need to have a world police
and you need to have a world
military and you need to have a world
you know judiciary if you like and
i know this is going to sound
conspiratorial but the united states of
america is trying to do that basically
it's trying to create as many allies
with it as possible
and it's trying to be the world police
the world military and so on
so it's not just about human rights this
is an interesting guise
right for the fact that america wants to
encroach on as many countries
sovereignty as possible
and they do throw through the medium of
human rights
so we need to look at definitions
carefully hierarchies carefully
because as muslims and christians as
christians and muslims
we believe in god's right as the most
supreme right of all
now that's not indicated at all in any
of the human rights
and why or it not to be indicated
because of the secularism or the
secularistic
uh predis presupposition but we don't
believe in that
we're not secularists in that sense so
from that perspective i think
i agree me and you're both not
secularists because you'd identify
yourself as a christian
so we would want to see some of our you
know deities rights represented in this
right where about human what about um
mother's rights you know
30 of the articles that were written in
1948 in that convention
only the word mother i think comes once
in islam we have
a system where mothers come first you
know it's not mentioned in human rights
so we would say look we have our own
conception of human rights
where god comes first you know spouse
spousal rights
mothers rights husband's rights we have
our own conception and it
and it ranges from a societal
description
all the way to a domestic one all the
way through to a familial one
all the way up to a metaphysical one
that's our conception
and there's going to be a great deal of
overlap
and that's where we can have the
discussion but we can't start by saying
yes we must agree
that these are the objective human
rights that we all must universally
accept because
that conversation is unfair i believe
a lot of questions mashallah um let's
sister now and then we'll come to you
inshaallah
um in most of the conversations or
as you said um that we get very
apologetic
um do you have like more suggestions
next to what she said
to turn the conversation around yeah so
a lot of the lecturer was trying to give
you material for that right so
the most one of the most powerful things
in the world that you can do is ask a
question
okay asking a question unlocks
everything
right and usually the one who's asking
the question has the power
right that's not always the case but if
you just
think about three questions to ask them
about whatever presupposition they're
coming from
so for example the feminist right second
we're feminist it says how comes in
islam
you know no one brought out some
bringing out myself right because it's
usually the
issue of great controversy someone says
okay how is it the case that man for
example has different
inheritance laws to women in the quran
for example it shouldn't it be equal
the pre supposition is that different
things should be treated equally by the
way
whether it's anatomical and biological
and psychological difference
despite those differences which by the
way
second wave feminism feminists
acknowledge
if i said women as a more emotional than
men
do i sound misogynistic be honest a
little bit yeah if i say a
man is stronger he can control himself
better
you know a woman she gets emotional she
can cry
she should get palpitations she's
completely
say hold on man you're being
misogynistic say these are not my words
these are the words of simon
who is who the writer of the second sex
page 45.
wait a minute so i am so you're saying
all those things but but despite the
fact that
she she makes the case despite those
differences
there should be what there should be
equality we say well hold on
can you okay i'm willing to go along
please i'm really
happy to have this conversation with you
but before we continue i think it's fair
that you have to first justify that
first premise
where there is difference we should
still be equal can you elaborate
can you elaborate on that can you prove
that i mean no problem i'll
i'm willing to take that on board but
what you have to prove because you made
the claim
i mean the burden of proof was the one
who made the claim they've made the
claim here
so i'm i'm willing to listen to the
argument you just have to show me where
the principle of equality despite
difference should
ought to prevail over different
prescription where there is difference
for example right
so the point i'm making is one of the
best tactics is to
to question presuppositions and by the
way on that on that thing of um
inheritance we have a good researcher
with us called shif man
he's actually found that he did an
exhaustive voice called istikra
looking at all the cases and he found
that there are 20 major cases of
inheritance
16 of which by the way according to his
research
women get more than men did you know
that it's really interesting
where there's 20 different possible
cases of inheritance
16 of those cases despite the fact that
yeah the boy gets
we know those verses don't worry right
but despite that
women get actually more in 16 20 cases
so if there is an inequality here
it probably goes in the way of the woman
so let's uh we'll go to the next
question in child but you get
what i'm saying yeah there's already a
mic over there yes
yes thank you uh first of all i would
like to thank you for your excellent
presentation it was a great uh
insight you're gonna destroy this guy
man
as you were talking this guy's trying to
is it is it
gets wilder's here he's trying to kill
us or something
he found out where we are
thank you thank you guys sorry go ahead
it's okay thank you very much for your
excellent presentation it was a
crash course in in liberalism i also um
i also liked your accent very much it
was like listening to queen i like you
guys
so thank you for that um
so basically the the the the key element
of your speech
uh of questioning the question is a very
interesting one yeah
and on a micro level on an individual
level it is a very effective way to
um provide the
your colleague or your friend whatsoever
with another insight or another
perspective to create
more understanding between one another
the question i would like to ask is that
if you take that questioning the
question that concept that notion
to another level to a more strategic
level okay because i think the
underlying the underlying
uh idea of questioning the question is
to
influence the narrative to a certain
extent when you
when you influence a narrative there is
a way that you have the upper hand and
there is a way that you can teach the
other one
something so if you would take that
notion to another level to a more
strategic level
so not on a not on an individual level
but more let's say more on a political
level or a societal level
how would you advise us or what is it
what is your view on that how would how
do you think that we could
do that in the most effective way
possible i think formulating questions
and getting wider society to think about
them is one of the best techniques you
can do
okay really and you don't have to answer
everything i think your way of thinking
is excellent by the way right
you're thinking about how do we
implement these strategies on a wider
political level
and to change the narrative that's
exactly what we should be doing right
but we can't i mean thomas hobbs
since we've mentioned him today he says
man is but covenants are about words if
they're not backed by swords now i'm not
telling you to go get some swords
but what he's trying to say is that
you're only your word is only as worth
as much as your strength
so if you speak as loud as you can but
you're in a forest or in a you know
an empty room no one's gonna hear you
right so you need to put yourself
strategically in the right places
formulate the right arguments put
yourself in the right places
and keep keep rocking the boat
basically because if you don't rock the
boat we're not going to be able to once
again this idea we're not going to be
able to preserve our
children's futures we know now western
europe is becoming way more right-wing
it's unbelievable how it's working and a
lot of that is our fault because we're
not rocking the boat enough we're not
shouting as loud
to be fair as homosexuals shouted in
or as uh black people did in in and and
that's how they got their rights
right so what we're saying is
we need to rock the ball more and we
need to get more involved and it's going
to be for the future of our children
the way you're thinking is right just
keep thinking the way you're thinking
right put yourself in the right places
and ask the right questions but must be
in the right places though
yep yes
right here by the way
hello there i am um
i have a pro-life question um
liberals tend to be very pro-choice and
you see more and more advocate
for um the liberal position being
abortion on demand without apology with
no exception
and preferably until birth so
as a christian that obviously is a thorn
in my eyes so
because i'm ruggedly pro-life i'm
hardcore pro-life
yes and as a christian i see many
christian
organizations that uh advocate for the
pro-life position in the public domain
but i
barely if any see any uh islamic
pro-life organizations so my question is
two-pronged
number one is do you know of any uh
islamic organizations that argue for the
pro-life position
in in the public domain and
two what is your take on the islamic
position of the pro-life
uh argument i think very good questions
an excellent question in fact you know
but within christianity there is a
spectrum as well so catholics are
usually way more rigid than protestants
and i think the sunni position
and usually the shiite position as well
is more in line with the protestant
reasoning than it is with the catholic
one
so we don't believe that conception
happens
when obviously sorry that life happens
at conception
we believe that there is either 40 or
120 days
where in which you know the um hadith
uh you know in ahadeth
one of you is going to be 40 days sorry
i'm just getting the hadith
the hadith is that if one of you is
going to be in your mother's room for 40
days
and then they will become scholars say
that the the the soul the insolent
period
is either from 40 to 120 days
i follow the hamburglar school of
thought which says 40 days so anything
before 40 days
is possible to have an abortion anything
after 40 days
i don't accept that unless there is some
kind of extenuating circumstance
and there are some extenuated
circumstances there are some scholars in
islam which go further than that
and so on now that's point one so in
terms of that so we don't we're not as
rigid as the catholic position
we're more in line with the protestant
position point two to be honest with you
if we see christians doing a good job we
leave them to it
okay usually all right so some things
that christians are arguing for and
doing
that we can't do okay do you do you do
that
some christians to be fair in south
america and other parts of america
to be honest are putting us all kind of
you know making us embarrass just like
some muslims make us embarrass as well
because they're blowing up abortion
clinics and those
things as well that's problematic for us
i'm sure it's problematic for you
so i think there is there is scope for
this for agreement
there can be collaboration here there
are points of interest but
for us the reason why we're not talking
about abortion as much
which is a big problem right especially
when it's done after
let's say in these some countries some
states apparently after six months some
ridiculous things like that
which we would see as murder as is
killing someone right
uh and you'd have to pay blood money and
all those things in islamic law
and the reason why we're not involved in
that as much is because we're too busy a
lot of the time
looking at how much of our children that
you know already born
are being killed in foreign policy right
so
that's the issue i think we're trying to
prioritize minority groups
what to talk about first second and
third your right to have a concern
and you're right to think that we should
be more involved but
usually when the christians once again
do a good job of something we usually
lead them to it
jews would probably have more of an
influence on the
bottom you know maybe we could
help you in some way shape or form but
we'd have to be in
in in compliance with our own principles
and i agree with your sentiments to a
great extent
thank you the other microphone places
in front i want to i want to ask
when looking at the liberal laws for
example in america what
holds more weight when for example
children
must pledge allegiance to the flag in
the morning at the school
or the freedom not to achieve not to do
that
or would that be uh treason so
in according to their loss what holds
more weight or more uh
yeah i don't think they would deem it
treason if the kid decides not to do it
by the way
um but there are some things i mean
every state once again there are states
which have
certain requirements for treason to take
place
and so we have to be very specific as to
how we're making the argument
um yeah i mean that's one of the things
which shows that there's a nationalistic
underpinning you're right
the whole allegiance to the flag thing i
mean desecrating a flag in many
countries in liberal countries is seen
as a criminal offence
and that shows you the extent to which
for some reason republican
liberal states decide where and where
you know how
where and how they can determine freedom
of expression
it shows a contradiction in their
principles so it's good to outline that
from that perspective that this is a
contradiction your principles
because it's not in line with the
freedom expression you promised in the
first instance
that's how i would kind of argue it
the mic is in the middle somewhere yeah
hello so i come uh
thank you for your speech i have a
question um
what is the main cause with regard to uh
people from the west
or liberals um we try to force down
their standard of norms and values and
what can we as muslims
do about this the reason why they do it
is the reason why
anyone does believes that their morals
are true
it's usually because they've been
socialized into believing in that
like for example if we were all born in
ancient greece
and we were you know we saw athena as
one of the greek gods
and we knew that this god was
responsible for this and this
it would be ingrained in our culture so
much so that we might just feel it
almost natural if you like you know and
so they've been brought up into this and
they can't
strip themselves away from this paradigm
this box
is really difficult for them to take
themselves out of
and so it's you do have to
engage with people in order to take them
outside of that box so they can see that
actually this is a rigid box with its
own
you know problems and so on and it has a
certain amount of dogma attached to it
as well so i think that
it's difficult for anybody in any
society to see above and beyond their
world view but with liberalism the
problem is that that's a problem because
liberalism itself talks about it doesn't
have any
fixed positions on certain moralities
and then to also and the issue is on
foreign policy that if you take this
liberalism which is meant to be
espousing the self-expression of someone
and spread it
you know that's the real problem this
new conservative
understanding of liberalism is the most
problematic of all because how can you
force someone to
i mean you're forcing someone to be free
it's a that's a paradox i mean
you're talking about priorities that's
that's the real problem so
i think generally it's difficult for
people to think like that because
they're born and raised
you know and it allows them to live a
very kind of heedless lifestyle frankly
you know i don't know how it is in the
netherlands but you know we have a pub
culture in our country in uk i'm sure
that you have it as well yeah
it's tomorrow king's day or something
yeah yeah great park so make sure you
stay home
so so it allows them to live their life
without any regrets but really they have
the most regrets because if you look at
suicide rates and if you look at
depression rates
this lifestyle isn't doing it for them
on a psychological level
less question in the front so make it a
good one you said uh liberalism
liberalism has nothing to offer to islam
because
it it's not based on objective morality
which you've demonstrated very well
tonight
but what would you reply to a liberal
who in turn
questions the objective morality of
islam and is in the real
question here tonight uh the objective
morality of islam versus the
subjectiveness
of liberalism so a liberal would say
well what makes
islamic morality objective the thing is
it's not just islamic um morality
but it's the idea of theism itself right
where you have
a transcendent entity which is all
knowing all wise and all powerful
which can endow these agents
agencies with free will and the ability
to make it or they'll be able to make a
decision
and also you know morality if morality
does not come from such a transcendent
being such that if you wipe off all of
the
humans on the earth that the morals
would stay the same
right then it's difficult to make a case
for objective morality
therefore i would say that
if you want to argue on theism you'd
have to prove theism
on first principles so maybe an argument
for the existence of god
real and then attached to that something
about the omnipotence and the
all-knowing nature of god
once you realize such an agency exists
then it makes sense that such an agency
can would uh and has endowed human
beings with such morality
and from there you can have a discussion
but
the only to be honest with you in the
history of philosophy only a few
philosophers have actually dared to say
you know
we have a mechanism not that there are
objective immorals there are many people
who say that
but we have a mechanism for objective
morality one of them was emmanuel kant
he had this belief of the categorical
imperative i'm not going to go into it
but everyone has not anything but it's
been criticized this belief
the mechanism itself is really
problematic but the idea
is you can't it's very difficult it's
very difficult to
have a mechanism like that and so
philosophers have not really bothered
apart from afar a few of them in number
and so
if you argue on theism then obviously
you can say objective mind it comes from
the all-knowing god simple as that
if you don't argue on theism it becomes
very difficult emmanuel kant found it
very difficult
and he's been criticized with his
mechanism of the categorical imperative
but not many people believe in
this objective morality can be proven
mechanistically if you like
you